de toute façon si vous me permettez
cette mauvaise comparaison ça sera
toujours la course entre les les
gendarmes et les voleurs on sait très
bien qu'à chaque fois qu'on réhaussera
nos dispositifs il se passera d'autres
choses chez les trafiquants je vous
évoqué tout à l'heure que l'imagination
et et et sans fin chez chez les
trafiquants enfin dans dans les saisies
maritimes enfin dans les interpellations
maritimes qu'on fait on trouve quand
même des choses assez extravagantes
entre les gens dans des containerses les
sont soudés sous les caisses avec de la
[Musique]
drogue c'est c'est c'est quand même ça
prouve et la cocaïne cette particularité
aussi d'être assez camouflable dans des
liquides ou dans des pâtes
euh vous en trouvez quelquefois dans
dans dans l'armature même du navire hein
donc faut démonter le bateau pour parce
qu'elle a été mélanger à des panneaux de
bois à des
vêtements donc faut faut faut bien avoir
conscience de de ce que c'est quoi et
donc on sait très bien que si on arrive
à rehausser le dispositif containire on
limitera parce que c'est là où passent
les gros
tonnages plusieurs quand on trouve 4
tonnes de cocaïne en principe c'est pas
sur sur une personne mais de toute façon
on va être confronté après à des des
d'autres choses d'autres choses il y a
quand même il y a quand même des
semiubmersiv a quand même enfin c'est
des gens qui ont énormément d'argent
énormément de moyens et qui de toute
façon vont servir des évolutions
technologique voilà